90 blogger bekommen immer näher 70 73
blöcke der letzte gegner
60 ich hoffe mal da ist einfach richtig
liegen können von menschen
wir haben
servus sg zwar herzlich willkommen zu
einer zwei drei vier fünf runden ändern
heute mit einem sprechen dessen zwar ich
meinen kollegen zu suchen
während max mit seinem austauschpartner
in frankfurt ist schön wenn hier noch in
bestimmte frage wie haben ihre pläne
geändert
leute ihr müsst mich verstehen die habe
im moment auch pläne geändert habe mich
verhört
aber ich kann nicht sagen wo die genau
sind weil dann wisst ihr wo wir wohnen
so die holzkiste und habe jetzt einfach
mal eine schöne gelegenheit manieren
runder games zu spielen weil ich ewig
einfach wirklich ewig nicht mehr einfach
so ender ganz gespielt habe und wie
spiel heute das känguru kit ganz cool
so wie ich früher meine spielt ab und
schauen einfach mal die das so läuft und
was ich alles noch kann bittet
persönlichkeit scheiße nur 81 immer eine
dumme zahl ja mal so wir machen das
einfach für die armut im alter
was hältst du davon nutzen goldhelm ist
das modisch vertretbar oder mehr grad
doch so als bin ich nicht so der fan
davon persönlich würde sagen ja
gold gold und eisen oder alten schulen
gold nicht beurteilen
in der eisen und gold helden sind besser
als gold helm und
eigentlich beides nicht aber weil
deshalb ist er zu gast
danke dass du möchtest das zelt er ist
schon mal passé alles klar und es geht
weiter macht ihr so eine entspannte
runde vorgestellt haben hier als känguru
ein bisschen rum jumper so geht der muss
man später habe ich hab weggepackt
das bin ich den fans freuen das ist ganz
schlecht känguru im wasser ist ganz
schlecht dass das passieren zuerst
einmal kurzzeitig das brot herein zu
fräsen und wir im genug eisen für eine
show behindert wäre zu behinderten
dieses ding dazu bauen lassen ab mal die
kraft menschen stehen am als genug zeug
gucken einfach mal was unser nächster
gegner der ihnen sofort 450 blogger ja
aber wie gesagt das eigentlich relativ
kalt wie viel grad sind heute also hier
schwimmbad überhaupt keinen fall aber ja
gut für die als besonnen vielleicht aber
hier mehr als 20 grad aber nicht mehr
sonne geht eigentlich aber ja aber wie
viel grad sind sendung alle letzte weg
letzter tag habe ich mir meine calgary
bahn keine handeln kann ich da müsst ihr
forsches gefallen und der ist leider in
frankfurt schon bei dem longboard also
frankfurt ist gleich um die ecke ist
sogar ziemlich weit weg aber froh dass
meine tolle stadt
viel schöner als münchen nicht wenn
jemand frankfurt main frankfurt ist
natürlich ein heftiger schlag besser als
zum juni von der weg verläuft wo das ist
nicht die kleine firma group inc eng her
komm her kangoo 1 übrigens das kind also
nicht die ganze chose so heißt dieses
teil bis das set an fähigkeiten für
mitarbeiter
mega hoch oder wenig vergleichs punkte
oder gut zum ewig alles klar
die nächsten gegner er wollte ich glaub
ich in gebraten gold ab betrachten das
sieht ganz danach aus da kann man ja 24
stunden update sehr gut die ansage
machen wir es mal wieder her
was denkst du hatten gold ab und fünf
funktionen kannst mal raten also goldene
abgepasst kann der goldene apfel werde
ich nur ausgelacht hab keine ahnung
irgendwas du bist jetzt du bist jetzt
minecraft entwickler für dieses neue
team ein
diese neu dafür aber überlegen was kann
wenn er hart ist kann man natürlich
einen wald gefällt noch relativ weit
gefehlt
aber raten weiter was könnte es sein
dass könnte es sein
wenn er gold ist sehr wertvoll sein weiß
nicht ob das was mit leben zu tun hat
leben ist eine heiße spur lebensnah
heiße spur frucht kann man essen
das würde ich so stehen lassen aber
läutet kommt vorerst nicht glaube ich
ist korrekt ist korrekt dass ist der fc
energie
der ist ja richtig abdeckt
oder obersten entscheidet ist ihr
schwert ach du scheiße ach du scheiße
das wird richtig für uns weggehauen
heftig alter ok krass egal einfach
nächste runde wie wär's denn die tiger
spieler bereits alle staaten der flower
verrückt
die sollen auch sagen was der gold ab
geprägt ein bisschen abwechslung dieser
wunsch firma mit viel zucker dass nicht
auch ziemlich früh hab ich ja letztens
übrigens vorgestellt da liest du nicht
gesehen habe fand ich das anschauen und
was wolltest du besser als wir wollen
nach verbringt er ich musste darauf
lösen der goldene apfel bringt zwei
extra herzen bitte leben ja ich sag doch
leben ist eine heiße spur hat was
komplett richtig heiße spur leben lebens
relativ oder bzw erleben kann vieles
sein
das ist schon ein leben leben ist keine
ahnung so philosophisch warum hat
eigentlich können wir eigentlich gar
nicht sein denn so eine aufnahme wir
können auf jeden fall in die kommentare
schreiben
ob ihr denkt das leben der treffende
beschreibung von gold apfel ist oder ob
robert einfach ein kleiner kater hast du
dich leben das game ab ich wollte ein
känguru sprung machen funktioniert nicht
weil wir da dies doch klar die
golfschuhe zwischenahn
diese löcher in den bäumen und in den
wänden sind immer aus wie eine fest dass
ich so verwirrend für mich oder heroin
schon gesagt ja ich weiß dann bei dem
studio niemals vorher sehen genauso aus
wie ändert schützenjahr läuft bis schon
minecraft werde drei jahre lang hat er
mir tipps gegeben jetzt bin ich als 10
219 verschwindet findet okay bisher
haben wir einfach nur gold wert aber
leider eine allzu wenigen die besten ein
paar diamanten wo ich will die ganze den
känguru sprung machen
das ist so verwirrend wenn du erst mit
känguru spielt also der kriegt das kind
keine doppelspur machen kann zwar
springen und dann hier mit walking ziel
super das ist ganz schwer das zu laufen
damit aber kaum noch werden die ihr
schwer
das reicht sehr gut alles klar die
anderen ihr schwert und einige pfeile
schön gemacht robert feldmeier als chili
sauce was anders ist es nicht
chili sauce
churchill in diesem modus an hier ist
eine mittlere niveau ist der probiert
jetzt schon mal gestorben und der andere
dinge töte das heißt wir geben nicht auf
den von kraftwerken eine rüstung was den
ganzen teilnehmen dtm ist nicht worte
ich mich leider erschließen wenig zu tun
haben wir schon ein ganzes geht perfekt
auf sehr gut
chillige sachen ja genau zwölf monaten
der wand verwandten liegen relativ
ungefährlich leider immer noch kein food
essen ja von den kollegen der unten gibt
es essen und er hatte einfach kein essen
hat er mich angelogen nicht nicht in
ordnung von dir nicht in ordnung und ich
hab ich gesagt man könnte ihr vertrauen
war leider nicht der fall
deswegen müssen wir weiter suchen auf
unserer großen quest nach essen wir
können aber nicht mehr sprinten dann
sind wir am arsch da sich daten die
hunger arbeitender oder ja ja ja
genau diese leckerei ruhig auch mal
reinbeißen
obwohl wir von denen nur drei haben dann
können nicht mal rennen dann sind
einfach ein gefundenes fressen für so
ziemlich alles und jeden
oder ist sehr gut wunderbar
die spanisch können das land richtig
du konntest mitte januar konnten und
können konnten ja hab ich gesagt die
bahn die stars egal ob denn hier drauf
hätte einsatz blöcke e10 hat ja sehr gut
sehr gut sehr gut gemacht der migros
jetzt keinen fall ein bisschen reifen
die runde dauert jetzt schon elf minuten
zu machen wir einfach schnell findet
will ich sagen weil das wird
wahrscheinlich auf 14 15 hinaus laufen
aber ich denke mal ist auch noch in der
mehrzahl etwas länger folge machen okay
da ist jemand live der csu der instinkt
trader sich 1 alles klar
aber ich bin eigentlich bin ich also
nicht so lola paket soll ich mit dem
fall rücken alles geklappt
es geht noch nicht so dramatisch
er versteckt sich die kommen jetzt
wahrscheinlich geändert überraschen
aber hätten wir zwei jahren weniger
klargemacht sagen ja sehr gut sehr gut
schillig alles klar
ja ich sollte mich nicht so viel selbst
aber ich bin einfach so angespannt wenn
ich gegen den weiteren denn die ganze
anspannung von mir abfällt wenn ich mir
so dann musst du erst mal pushen 67 bis
zum nächsten werde meine sache mit
ironie gewinnen könnten
momentan sagt manchmal bloß nicht mal
fußball spielen steht so jemand am
feldrand und einfach mental so der
psychologe
ja und der ist lola der ist nun live
alles live irgendwie durch gefühl
dann schaut man dem kind auch mal einen
kleinen besucher beim einziehen besucher
instinktsicher aktiviert dann die
familie abend sehr schön der kanzlerin
wenig machen im wasser
ganz wichtig jetzt mal die gleiche
quelle ende bringen sagt okay das ist
auch recht viel eingesteckt ich weiß gar
nicht warum warte jetzt irgendwie
delfinen oder hatte mut gehabt nein
haben wir wie alle tiere einfach kein
essen
das wird so heftig gegen den das wird so
heftig wir haben einfach kein essen mehr
seht ihr am herzen können weil ich mal
sprint haben kein essen und haben noch
einen gegner gegen und der
wahrscheinlich ziemlich guter christ
water [ __ ] okay das war's wir können
nicht mehr spenden
ja ja weiter ausgebaut karten sehr gut
wie kräfte man brot ich hab's vergessen
sagt normal bitte eroberte sterben sonst
musst du da einsetzen wo also extra
heute gebraucht ja ich weiß ist auch so
gut
weißt du noch zu schätzen okay ein hat
ein 60 blogger der kommt ja ja die rund
40 minuten
dass die dann auch zu einem ende kommt
und zwar zu einem glorreichen ähnlich
wie die und jetzt gewinnen ich will
gewinnen ich habe so hart gekämpft dafür
als känguru so unschön kassiert für mich
jetzt als ziel so war der brite mal
die hoffentlich wohl verdienten
lorbeeren einsammeln können
90 blogger bekommen immer näher 70
blöcke 70 werke der letzte gegner 60
entfernt von uns
wenn nichts mehr geht
alles war bis jetzt ziemlich nah dran
den bereich blöcke ich hoffe mal da ist
einfach richtig erwischen wir haben
damit ja wohl sehr gut
haben wir doch gewonnen sehr gut also
wirklich gefallen könnten leichter
lassen ihr könnt in die kommentare
schreiben ob wir mehr von solchen ender
games haben wollt vielleicht auch mal
eine runde wo man spielt